bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 15 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de vous inviter mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition
jabra entreprises spécialisées dans
l'audio installe ses bureaux elles
encourent présente sur saint quentin en
yvelines depuis maintenant de 20 ans la
société de plus de 20 salariés a
inauguré un nouveau site dans le parc
d'affaires d'oméga parker le premier
réseau d'auto stop dans les yvelines va
être officiellement lancée dès le 9
avril ont cette explication pour nous en
parler en plateau armelle qui toi
président de pouce civile et enfin le
groupe accor avait amené il ya vingt ans
leur credo faire découvrir au public les
classiques revisités
quand ils ne sont pas invités sur france
2 par jean françois zygel il parcourt
l'europe
il était en concert ce samedi avec
rencontre est installé à saint quentin
en yvelines depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans la société danoise à jabra vient
d'inaugurer des bureaux dans le parc
d'affaires de médiapart kyle en cours
spécialisés dans l'audio l'entreprise
emploie plus d'une vingtaine de salariés
sur le site est bon pour toi
la filière française est en pleine
croissance comme l'expliqué fanny
bourdillon et mélanie poké après
montigny le bretonneux et rap c'est
dorénavant à elancourt que la société
jabra à sa filiale
si la société a déménagé elle a tout de
même voulu rester sur saint quentin en
yvelines
pourquoi ce choix parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une région très technologique
d'accord avec beaucoup de savoir faire
technologique nous avons un voisin la ds
nous avons des sociétés dans ce groupe
d'immeubles qui sont ou sur des parties
financière ou cédés par titre et
technologies qui correspondent
complètement à notre environnement de
tous les jours installé sur
l'agglomération depuis plus de 20 ans
jabra france emploie 25 personnes sur le
site d'elancourt la société qui fait
partie d'un groupe danois est
spécialisée dans l'audio et notamment la
téléphonie mobile aussi bien sur une
branche qui fait des appareils pour de
mesures auditive pour les mener
les hôpitaux et enfin une troisième
division qui fait des appareils pour
malentendants dispositifs d'aidés
auditives jabra met en avant une
croissance de 14% du chiffre d'affaires
pour l'année 2015 par rapport à l'aller
2014 retour à présent sur la crise
agricole alors que les ministres de
l'agriculture de différents pays se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à bruxelles pour
trouver des solutions
la fédération des vignes du parti
communiste français organisé samedi une
rencontre avec un agriculteur de la
ligue
comment mettre en place une économie
sociale et solidaire comment améliorer
la situation des agriculteurs et des
producteurs
ce sont les différents points qui ont
été développées lors de ce débat les
précisions avec camille lambert crise
agricole et économie sociale de thème au
centre des discussions samedi 13 février
à trappes
la fédération des yvelines du parti
communiste français a organisé un débat
dans ses locaux le responsable du
syndicat paysan modef du département de
l'allier a fait le déplacement pour
témoigner de ces difficultés là on
développe on explique toute la
problématique du monde agricole telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc aux consommateurs ça permet de se
rapprocher je dirais entre agriculteurs
et consommateurs entre producteurs et
consommateurs
l'objectif de cette rencontre trouver
des solutions afin d'améliorer la
situation des agriculteurs fixer des
prix rémunérateurs mais aussi
privilégier les filières courtes pour
supprimer les intermédiaires et les
marges de la grande distribution des
pistes développer auprès des
consommateurs par le parti communiste
pour sensibiliser la population donc
parfois au travers de réseaux qu'on
connaît parfois en distribuant des
tracts pour informer et donc les gens
sont venus et se sont montrés intéressés
qui sont très contents d'avoir une
viande de qualité et en même temps de
rencontre et l'agriculteur c'est pour
eux un gage de traçabilité et de sérieux
une initiative ou le producteur serait
lui aussi gagnant en 2014 30 % des
agriculteurs de l'allier avait une
situation financière critique
aujourd'hui il serait 40% ça apporterait
donc un revenu plus intéressant et on
pourrait vivre de notre travail ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup de gens qui ont des
trésorerie négative et qui peine de plus
en plus à s'en sortir sur leur
exploitation
selon un rapport de l'institut de veille
sanitaire paru en 2013 environ 500
agriculteurs se sont donné la mort entre
2007 et 2009
prochainement la fédération des yvelines
du parti communiste français organisera
des ventes directes avec des exploitants
et nous vous en parlions au mois de
septembre le projet d'auto stop sur le
territoire il vit noah avec pouces 10
lignes depuis cinq mois cette initiative
a bien évolué et va être officiellement
lancée le 9 avril prochain pour en
parler ce soir en plateau avec nous
armelle pitois président de
l'association pouces divine bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors justement
tout d'abord le réseau est ce qu'on
pourrait expliquer le réseau de stop aux
élus qu'est ce que c'est en quoi ça
consiste
alors pour vivre le but est de dupliquer
un dispositif qui existe en fait du côté
de moissac pas très loin de montauban et
c'est sur le principe c'est de l'auto
stop organisé alors par rapport de
l'auto-stop classique
les gens en fait vont s'inscrire aussi
bien les conducteurs que les passagers
vont s'inscrire à l'association et en
échange de quoi ils auront un kit
conducteur et passager qui comportera en
fait un macaron un petit badge ahmed
comme une vignette sur le pare brise de
l'auto et en plus de ça on travaille
avec les collectivités les collectivités
pour rajouter en fait des arrêts
sécurisée sur la voirie donc c'est
sécurisé dans le sens où de plus les
gens en fait quand ils s'inscrivent il
est une pièce d'identité
voilà pas de risque que ça c'est
justement par le biais d'un site
internet on s'inscrit donc dans une
commune comment ça se passe les secours
alors on il ya deux possibilités l'une
cédait s'inscrire dans les communes
adhérentes
donc aujourd'hui on est on est à onze
communes et autrement sur le site
internet de réseaux pouces ou vous allez
sur la page de pouce divine et vous
pouvez vous inscrire alors justement
cette saison vous tv lancée ça s'est
inspiré justement de réseaux pouces qui
englobe toute la france voilà en fait
les l'idée est partie de moi ça comme je
vous précise tout à l'heure et
maintenant on est vraiment c'est un
système qui est vraiment en pleine
expansion puisqu'en début 2015 et il y
avait peut-être 90 communes fin 2015 140
on est sur des prévisions à 400-500 fin
avril et avec des prévisions de 900
communes à la fin la fin de la mi-2016
donc c'est vraiment une grosse expansion
c'est vraiment un système plan devenu
donc vous même vous êtes en lien
justement avec les autres communes
en france qui réalisent qu'ils sont du
réseau pouces vous avez des retours
positifs qu'elles sont appelées ses
chances il faut remonter les échanges
mais justement nous étions en formation
avec avec d'autres
personne en fait de l'île de france
puisque le parc naturel du gâtinais
souhaite aussi lancer ces dispositifs en
septembre nous étions aussi avec eux
d'autres d'autres responsables de
différentes régions en france et l'idée
c'est que l'on sent vraiment que ne
serait ce que par les sessions de
formation qui va vraiment y avoir
beaucoup de monde à se lancer et pas
seulement en région parisienne encore
une fois nous en yvelines on va être les
précurseurs
mais ça va vraiment être dans tous les
coins de la france parce que tant en ile
de france il ya que dans les îles
viennent que justement voilà le réseau
pouces sept moines de se dépasser lancé
oui c'est une grande première c'est une
grande première c'est aussi une fierté
en quand on a lancé le sujet en fait on
a d'abord voulu c'est sûr et qu'on était
bien légitime à le faire donc c'est pour
ça qu'on nous avons rencontré la région
ile-de-france vraiment au tout départ et
donc nous avons aussi été labellisé par
régions de france puisque nous avons
reçu une subvention de 50 mille euros et
j'irai un petit peu la cerise sur le
gâteau nous étions aussi présent sur le
stand de la région lors de la cop 21
alors justement là comme 21 il ya
beaucoup d' avantages écologiques on va
dire à participer à ce réseau pouces
divine
qu'est ce que vous nous avez rappelé
voilà en termes d'économies budgétaires
mais aussi pour la planète
alors oui très clairement l'idée l'idée
à la base était de lutter contre l'auto
solis mme c'est à dire essayer de
partager
jirel la voiture à plusieurs
donc là nous sommes dans un cadre
vraiment d'un covoiturage de proximité
sur de petites distances et qui va
rendre service à des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément accès à la mobilité je pense
notamment aux lycéens je pense aux gens
qui nous ligne avec une voiture par
foyer
alors c'est vrai que dans les divines
c'est peut-être un petit peu plus rares
mais quoique on a vraiment des
disparités suivant les communes et
suivant les
des parties du département et puis ma
foi c'est pour les gens qui n'ont
quelles que soient leurs conditions qui
n'ont pas accès à la voiture ou qui ne
veulent pas conduire c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment une opportunité alors on
le rappelle c'est complètement gratuit
l'initiative va bientôt être mises en
place donc à partir du 9 avril
comment va fonctionner un peu le réseau
de nos stocks de façon pratique comment
va se passer également aller les
réunions alors les réunions publiques on
commence dès dès demain en fait à marcq
alors vous pouvez retrouver en fait les
informations sur le site de poésie vie
nous avons déjà onze communes ses
marques touahri mére bazoches sur
guyonne voici sans avoir ces religions
divines marie leguillon les minul
immense et villiers le mahieu et qui
vers lannion comme ça je n'oublie
personne
et il ya d'autres communes qui vont à
qui vont arriver on est vraiment
pourparlers avec plein de collectivités
donc c'est vraiment géré partie sur la
bonne piste mais lors de ces réunions
justement on va préciser aux jo public
les modalités en fait l'utilisation du
dispositif et puis il répondra à toutes
les questions
donc si voilà on va avoir plus
d'information on n'y vont pas se
proposait également en tant que couvrait
de fureur alors en fait il faut vraiment
venir la palais à la source aux
renseignements et puis ma foi ça va
faire la démarche de s'inscrire ou en
mairie ou sur le site internet
alors justement pour pour s'inscrire on
se met directement en relation avec vous
alors il ya moyen de faire directement
sur le site internet de réseaux pouces
et puis
vous inscrivez en fait toutes les
démarches que vous pourriez faire aux
mairies vous les faites sur le site
internet
maintenant nous conseillons de se
rapprocher des mairies pour les gens qui
habitent en fait sur les mairies
adhérentes ou à proximité
si on veut soutenir votre projet voilà
plus plus dur à demander mieux ça
marchera et plusieurs autres
collectivités
mais encore une fois je suis vraiment
très confiant parce qu'on a des contacts
un peu partout dans le département
je pense qu'on aura vraiment une grosse
implication des collectivités à terme je
pense que nos objectifs seront atteints
assez rapidement c'est que vous faites
un peu de la concurrence a décidé de
covoiturage comme blabla car vous avez
déjà eu des retours des approches par
rapport à ça alors c'est
c'est très bien vous en parliez non on
est vraiment sur quelque chose de
complètement différent on est vraiment
sûr de l'auto stop organisé
on ne vient pas là pour concurrencer qui
que ce soit on vient vraiment là en
transport ans pour compléter en fait les
transports en commun pour rabattre vers
les transports en commun le service est
gratuit pour les utilisateurs donc on
n'est vraiment pas du tout dans une
démarche commerciale on n'est plus dans
une démarche de service public pour tout
simplement elle a essayé de rendre
service aux utilisateurs
alors qu'il ya les adhésions récente de
villiers le mahieu vous l'avez dit il
grignon l'association désormais onze
communes donc toi réméré vous en avait
parlé il ya aussi des contacts qui sont
courts avec justement d'autres communes
d'autres collectivités peut-être
d'autres plutôt dans le sud des yvelines
alors dans le sud dans le nord on est
vraiment un petit peu partout sur le
département on restera giradin sur sur
la zone rurale sur le territoire on va
dire de francs urbain on n'a pas de
vocation forcément aller dans des
centres villes qui sont vraiment très
bien desservi par les transports en
commun existants mais encore une fois je
pense qu'on va se propager très
rapidement très sûrement de giral rome
en partenariat avec les collectivités
parce que c'est le point de passage
incontournable ou bien vers
l'association aujourd'hui c'est les
majoritairement tenus par les
collectivités nous on a simplement en
tant que l'association fait la coquille
juridique et maintenant je dirais les
collectivités sont en train de s'emparer
du sujet et c'est très bien comme ça
c'est justement le réseau pouces s'étend
à toute l'île de france
on serait peut-être pas tout de suite
mais on peut penser que ça va arriver ce
serait d'autres associations ce serait
vous même qui aussi j'aimerais justement
à cette extension
alors non puisqu'on ne l'a pas souhaité
au départ où on reste sur le département
des yvelines réseau poussé nettement
mieux structuré que ça que nous en fait
pour aller vraiment mallet complètement
la région de france comme vous voulez
indiqué le père fait le parc naturel du
gâtinais qui joue un peu de publicité
faisait très bien pour eux vont se
lancer dans l'aventuré aussi en
septembre donc je reçois vraiment beau
de chance on essaiera travailler
vraiment avec le du mieux possible et y
aurait pour que tout le monde soit
gagnant dans l'histoire
merci beaucoup armelle pitois devenu
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors
s'ils voulaient justement plus
d'informations sur le réseau poussent et
poussent divine il ya les informations
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran merci à vous faut et enfin
connaissez-vous le home-staging
popularisé par des émissions de
télévision le relooking d'un bien avant
sa vente ou sa location est devenu très
fréquent dans l'immobilier
vous pouvez maintenant en profiter sans
forcément passer à la télévision où
accueillir une équipe de tournage chez
vous à voisins le bretonneux jodel s'est
lancé dans l'aventuré depuis septembre
dernier fanny bourdillon nous explique
le concept
regardez jodel a travaillé huit ans dans
l'immobilier
aujourd'hui elle se lance dans le home
staging qui permet de mettre en valeur
un bien pour ce deux pièces vides à
voisins le bretonneux
elle a d'abord travaillé avec des
croquis puis des maquettes de
photoréalisme en 3d l'a fait en laissant
un local
qui était anciennement un local
commercial qui est situé donc là dans
une zone de commerces 20 classés de la
mise en scène voilà proposer les vues de
la cuisine sur le salon comme moi style
pour agencer son salut et
rendre l'espace plus chaleureux
l'objectif rendre l'annoncent
immobilière plus clair et plus
attrayante car si les photos sont trop
simple l'appartement semble sans âme et
donc l'ange pas de visite
c'est pourquoi cette agence immobilière
de voisins-le-bretonneux fait désormais
appel à une home stager les acquéreurs
ou les locataires ou les futurs
locataires avant même de regarder
descriptif regarde d'abord les photos et
si les photos ne donne pas envie et
peuvent ils peuvent passer à côté de
quelque chose et qui correspondraient
pourtant de tout à fait à leur recherche
donc il faut qu'on leur donne envie il
faut il faut qu'on arrive à les
accrocher avec les vidéos 3d de jodel
cette agence projette à ses clients une
version numérique à 360° du local de
quoi percevoir tout le potentiel du bien
immobilier
car désormais plus nombreux que les
acheteurs les vendeurs doivent
convaincre et revenons sur les
événements du week-end hier dimanche 14
février à l'occasion de la
saint-valentin l'association
d'improvisation théâtrale des vies
signol organisé un spectacle spécial sur
ce thème à la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux chaque joueur
choisit un personnage qui l'ont dose
pendant 1h30 de match d'improvisation
pour voir se faire et se défaire
différents couples sur scène alors qui
de jean lejeune commercial via tient le
collant ou henriette la poissonnière
finira en couple phil et peu verissimo
président de l'association les singles
nous en dit plus regardez écoutez il y
aura un maître de cérémonie
au départ on va tous se présente et qui
dit rejeter le personnage est tel
personnage en temps de faire ça on
improvise là dessus quand la scène se
termine on dire au public
alors est-ce que ça match ou pas si
public trouve que le courant passe
qu'est un petit feeling et bien la
semaine suivante on les verra en couple
et nous restons sur le thème de la
culture comme chacun dise la chronique
culturelle de sephora namani sephora qui
vient nous présenter le groupe accordé à
metz que je le prononce bien sephora oui
c'est tout à fait cela accorde t aime et
on sait pourquoi parce qu'ils se donnent
à corps et âme dans leur musique donc à
coeur diam et et au théâtre des arts
quête de bus samedi soir pour leur
concert classique instinct l'occasion
pour moi de vous présenter ce groupe qui
s'inscrit dans cette nouvelle mouvance
néo trad néo traditionnelle alors encore
diam's est un groupe né
une vingtaine d'années sur les bancs de
l'école au collège précisément d'abord
sage au conservatoire ses cinq musiciens
de formation classique sont allés de
voyage en rencontrent pour créer un
univers riche et décalé se donne donc
coors et âme dans leur musique et en
explore toutes les facettes du baroque
au rock du traditionnel au jazz une
expertise du classique revisité les
détails avec raphael mailler violoniste
du groupe à cordes et âmes
ce que nous espérons arriver à
transmettre avec un corps d âme c'est de
faire comprendre au public que les
compositeurs de musique classique soit
disant respectables se sont toujours
inspiré des musiques traditionnelles et
des musiques populaires à destination de
la danse qui était soi disant moins
respectable donc nous essayons de faire
en sorte que ces musiques ne soit pas en
opposition mais plutôt en
complémentarité comme elles l'ont
toujours été
mais pour diverses raisons un petit peu
complexes tels que la révolution
française et le classement à la fnac
les musiques ont été catalogués alors
leur concert s'appelle classique
instinct pourquoi ce n'est pas une
référence au sénat non non non non mais
ils défendent vraiment un rapport
instinctif à la musique classique qu'il
cherche à ramener à ses origines
populaires et dansante
leurs influences musicales sont
multiples musique classique musique
tzigane musique du monde rock et c'est
vraiment à l'image de la pluralité de
tous leurs instruments de musique on
voit aussi bien du hautbois du violent
de la contrebasse pour le classique que
des percussions plus pour les sonorités
exotiques l'accordéon pour la danse bien
sûr et la guitare et la batterie pour le
côté rock
et
alors on aura reconnu au tout début et
la musique de pirates des caraïbes leur
dernier album s'appelle symphonie est ce
que leur spectacle est tiré uniquement
de ce dernier album alors pas que pas
tout à fait donc c'est vraiment le
produit de leurs trois derniers albums
c'est un concert vous avez pu l'entendre
très dansant très rythmé et très
dynamique avec des musiques populaires
mais également des musiques plus
classique plus savantes comme ils disent
et donc des musiques symphoniques
extraites de leur dernier album
symphonie symphonique est un travail
autour des compositions du compositeur
dvorjak et qui fraîchement immigrés à
new york en 1893 va entourer de toutes
les influences très cosmopolite de cette
ville créé l'une des premières oeuvres
symphoniques sont ni d'un nouveau monde
à mairie justement des influences très
éclectique dvorjak a dû composer une
musique américaine et que c'est donc
influencer tout c'est de toutes ces
cultures et nous avons essayé de faire
le chemin inverse donc on a réduit une
partition pour orchestre symphonique
pour notre quintette est hélas on
s'amuse avec les codes des musiques
traditionnelles et par la suite dans
l'album symphonique nous avons fait un
verre c'est à dire que nous avons écrit
et créé du répertoire traditionnel et
nous l'avons arrangé pour orchestre donc
nous avons inversé un petit peu voilà la
musique pour orchestre et jouée par un
quintet et la musique à l' origine
traditionnelle est joué par un orchestre
symphonique
vous l'avez compris c'est donc un
travail musical qui vient renverser les
codes du concert à leur accordait mais
tu me les festivals dans toute l'europe
la france la belgique la hollande la
hollande pardon ou encore l'allemagne
l'angleterre et à la hongrie la portugal
bref ils vont partout ils feront des
grands théâtres français comme par
exemple à vesoul
angers nancy ou encore au théâtre du
châtelet est ce qu'il vous repasser par
les yvelines prochainement sephora oui
prochainement oui on pourrait les
retrouver fin avril où ils s'associeront
à l' orchestre de l'agglomération du
grand parc de versailles pour un concert
de musiques de films un peu comme
l'extrait qu'on a pu voir et le 13
juillet prochain ils seront également
présents pour le grand bal de musique
populaire de versailles juste rappeler
le grand feu d'artifice et peut-être on
pourra vous y retrouver
alors en tout cas je vais tout de suite
c'est la date pour lequel on pourra
faire aussi également un reportage merci
sephora on vous retrouve mercredi dans
kiosques que vous nous en dire un peu
plus quel sera le programme du teasing
oui exactement alors donc il ya ce qu'on
va aborder le one man show mercredi avec
laurent seul c'est un élan courtois qui
tourne actuellement au guichet
montparnasse et puis dans deux semaines
je crois que je vais faire des heureuses
même à la rédaction parce qu'on va
recevoir lille lyon dubois jeunes
adolescents comédiens de la série de
france 2 qui fait un carton fais pas ci
fais pas ça et également oui genuini qui
participe actuellement à ce vol des
stars et donc sephora on a hâte de voir
ça
merci beaucoup on passe maintenant aux
sports montigny le bretonneux continue
sa belle série les hommes coachés par
hugo cyr et le mûrier et guy mathieu
grecque et occupe la troisième place du
championnat de première série ont
remporté une victoire importante contre
le 4e set 1 lors de la 13e journée du
championnat le score 15 à 13
résumé du match avec et mickaël mille
euros et camille lambert
c'est peut-être l'un des tournants de la
saison pour montigny le bretonneux en
première série les verts ont remporté un
match décisif dans la course au podium
contraste 1 ce dimanche à domicile dans
la boue et sous la pluie les i montant
se sont imposés à 15 à 13
elle te difficile à difficile à chercher
ont eu du mal mais on se donne les
moyens
et franchement c'est se mérite et la
joie ont été de 0,8
ça n'a pas été facile on n'agit pas
l'habitude pâle l'abitrage mais
l'arbitrage n'a pas nous a pas beaucoup
aidé mais les joueurs ont été héroïques
donc vous êtes rendu rendu que vous avez
dû vous en rendre compte son arrêt c'est
une quinzaine de minutes chez nous on
n'a pas pris d'essai ça c'est ça c'est
fabuleux vous avez été très très très
très très discipline à ce niveau là avec
cette troisième victoire consécutive
monty nos bottes ne se relance dans la
course à la montée les joueurs coachés
par le duo cyril mûriers guy mathieu gré
occupe la troisième place du classement
à 11 points du deuxième col imérien à
quatre journées de la fin même beaucoup
de temps sans n'a pas érodé à deauville
match vergnaud si on a réussi avant le
point de bonus on a réussi à aller
chercher une victoire dans des
conditions et limites
pourquoi on vise la montée on fera tout
pour y arriver
pour continuer à rêver de la montée
montillot bretons ne devra
obligatoirement s'imposer contre shell
lors de la 14e journée du championnat un
match programmé au stade robert barran
le 20 mars prochain
c'était bien le mode et je le rappelle
les bambous sont très bons pour la
pauvre plus de détails sportive tout de
suite avec elle elle me dit oh pardon
pour le 7-8 sport merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous donne rendez vous demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée